the first figure that we have for this
session is a yarun from gaudita driven
he is going to be about Dev containers
yerun he is a machine learning engineer
and he works on uh putting machine
learning models in production he is also
very active in the open source
communities many he has worked for many
open source packages uh and yeah his job
is about
containers so we are looking forward for
your talk please start thanks adamita
[Applause]
nice well thanks for the great
introduction and uh yeah I'm very very
happy to see so many faces here to uh
talk about Dev containers and before we
dive into the talk uh I would first like
to see a show of hands
um who has worked with Dev containers
before
all right yeah I see some some hands
there then another question out of the
people that have worked with Dev
containers who have has actively used it
at their companies
okay
some some less okay well then I see many
people that are unfamiliar still so then
that is great because we're gonna learn
about it together today
all right so first of all about uh about
me uh you already heard a little bit
that uh I'm a machine learning engineer
at go data driven which is an AI and
data consultancy company owned by xivia
and I help companies take their machine
learning applications into production
all right so first of all I want to
sketch a little bit of a of a use case
I want you to imagine that you are
setting up a new repository for a team
and you have the following requirements
you want to make an analytics
application so you want to do big data
processing with Apache spark so for that
you will need a system with the Java
also because you probably want to
develop it in Python we want to use Pi
Spark
and then naturally also python
so then we basically need to align with
the team
which Java version are you are we going
to use which python version and which Pi
spark version
and the reason why we need to do this is
that if we don't do this we don't get
the guarantees that we want in
production code
so whenever we go into production you
want to pin down the the versions
and then for that reason if everyone in
our team uses different versions has
different environments different laptops
different operating systems yeah it can
can get a bit tricky
and maybe to further emphasize okay what
can be potential problems here
I want to open up my Microsoft teams
window
and I have a couple of messages coming
in
so first get a message from Petra
Petra the Python death she is saying hey
my VM somehow got corrupted
it's saying no modulate numpy even
though I seemingly haven't installed not
sure how to fix PS this is also why I
was not in a meeting
so I'm pretty problematic Petra missed a
meeting because her fee and got got
broken okay this uh this is costing us
time
next message from Eric the old project
maintainer
hey so I was working on maintaining the
old projects just found out that some of
the dependencies don't even work on my
Mac OS version anymore
FML
all right so Eric he happened to have he
has to work on the old project basically
the the assumptions that were made when
the project was initially developed they
didn't hold anymore it was developed on
some operating system time went on the
operating system changed but the
environment was not fixed so it doesn't
work anymore
right next message from Billy windows
I'm trying to dockerize the project but
it's hard everything that works on my
Windows laptop seems to fill on Linux
all right so another problem here
Billy is trying to go into production
but developed his project on a Windows
machine but now wants to deploy it on a
Linux machine and it doesn't match
another message this time from Johnny Jr
hi can you maybe run pep show Pi spark
I'm curious which Pi spark you are
running because if it works for you but
not for me and also not in the CI maybe
your environment is different than both
just checking
in this case also Johnny Jr is kind of
confused why it doesn't work for him but
it works for some developer and then
yeah the the environments are not
reproducible in this way it's kind of
this principle what works for me oh but
it works for me just uh do whatever I
did on my system but then didn't maybe
document it or or that type of stuff
so then another message Johnny Jr good
day I'm new at the company and wanted to
get starting we started working on the
repo try following the readme steps but
doesn't work
by any chance are there any more
detailed talks available for the project
setup no right
so Johnny is new at the company he's
trying to to onboard but finds that just
following the readme steps doesn't work
maybe the documentation was written at
some point but then the environment
changed again not updating the docs and
then yeah without docs available this is
getting getting really hard
all right so let's maybe line up what
kind of issues did we did we run into
first we had Petra we had a corrupt
virtual environment
then Eric the old project maintainer he
has outdated project dependencies
with respect to the system or the
environment that it was initially built
for
then Billy Windows he has problems in
containerization and going into
production with a mismatch of systems
with the development machine and the
production environment
then there was Supply spark user which
was called Johnny Jr but he was actually
biospark user which has inconsistent
environments between local development
the CI environment production
environment and his other team members
so he wasn't sure why does it work maybe
for me and not in the CI and also not
for you there was inconsistencies here
and then Johnny Jr he was trying to
onboard but
there were no formal specifications of
of install steps maybe the preference
would have been not following this
incredibly long readme but having a
formal specification to configure his
environment get get started quickly or
maybe yeah at least have have up-to-date
uh dogs
all right so we have all these different
users with different different issues
how do we fix it
how do we get a reproducible Dev
environment
well the dev containers come to the
rescue so I'm going to to show you okay
how can we we build a Dev container for
for this use case and maybe why is it
why could it potentially be useful also
for you
all right so about the dev containers we
know Docker helps us create a formal
definition of our environment
and then def containers allow you to
connect your editor
to that container
so how that basically looks like is you
have an editor for example this is vs
code and then every every interaction
that you make for example running a test
doing debugging or running commands in
the terminal they actually
run inside the docker container
and so this gives you the benefits of
running a Docker container which is it's
reproducible is basically your
environment very neatly defined in a
Docker file
and then being able to reproduce that
and also in in isolation
may you just mess up your environment
you can actually rebuild it
whilst still giving you the native
development experience so while still
having vs go there which feels native
still
so what does this mean
if it's reproducible then it means we
can onboard faster
your your deaf environment has been
defined neatly it can be reproduced you
don't no longer have to say Okay follow
these 20 steps and maybe try to
replicate my environment but it's rather
okay I have this script it automatically
configures your your environment which
is the docker file
also better alignment between team team
members because whenever you want to
change the environment you have to
reflect it also in your in your Dev
container and therefore
other team members can basically pull
changes to the environment by pulling
your in your new Docker image
and also a smaller Gap to production
which is because you are already
maintaining this formal definition
you're already maintaining the docker
image so if that is already already
built you no longer run into the
problems where you you build it on one
machine you configured your one machine
to be perfectly suited for for your
application and now you have to go into
production and dockerize it it kind of
forces you to already do this
so what are the downsides
the downside says you are introducing
Docker so you will have to be familiar
with Docker maybe know how to write a
Docker file your system will have to
support it although it has very wide
support
so did this is one trade-off that you
will make you will introduce a docker
and you might get nice benefits for it
in return
all right so
that said let's see how do we actually
build one
all right so for this application that I
previously mentioned for which we need
uh Pi Spark
running in a python environment we have
this project setup which is just two
python files a test file and then two
files explaining the the requirements
for a project
very very simple and then we actually
adding a DOT Dev container folder
so in this dot def container folder we
are adding two files devcontainer.json
and a Docker file
and we'll start with gdap container.json
I put in here the most minimal amount of
Json required just to create a Dev
container we'll be extending it later
so in the dev container.json file you
can see there is a reference to to a
Docker file this basically means to
create my Dev container take this Docker
file which lives in the dev container
folder and build it from within the
working folder that is one parent folder
up
so then what does the docker file look
like
this is quite a lot of text let me focus
on one thing
first we're taking as a base python 3.10
which is probably image familiar to you
guys
and here we're installing uh Java so we
need Java in order to run all the the
spark related operations
also do two times a pip install
first the requirements.txt file and then
the requirements def
uh file and then we're also separating
them because
you might want to get only the
production requirements when you're
building a production image
all right so that was pretty simple uh
dock file
then now we actually already built it
like a most minimal specification of of
this Dev container so let's see how do
we open it
first given that you have installed Dev
containers extension in vs code
there's this this command
which is called reopening in container
which you can execute to to open the the
container given that you have this dot
Dev container folder in your in your
project
and then at this point it might be nice
to notice okay people are saying okay
this is uh vs code right uh I use
pycharm
or I use even another editor
so what what is currently happening in
this Dev container space is that they're
very very heavy developments coming from
the vs code team to put the dev
container specification into an open
specification so they're currently
creating a specification that is
agnostic for for editors so I'm also
showing you this agnostic specification
it's really been heavy development in
all the couple last months year
so I'm showing you the specification
that is agnostic for for the editors but
still it will it will work only for for
vs code now
so of course the hope is that this open
specification will be supported by by
all the editors then basically you get
your one Dev container specification
use any Editor to open it so they're
really
really trying to to push this to become
like one one standard so because yeah if
if it only works for vs code yeah that's
that's quite limited we want just one
nice specification to create and use Dev
containers
all right going further now
just assuming the rest is in uh fees
code
already also if he is called the text
okay I think you have a Dev container
configuration file here do you want to
reopen it in the container so it gives
you this notification maybe I just click
here
and then I can see okay I'm just open up
the the desktop now there's Fierce code
here uh given that I push this button it
now says on the left
the bottom corner opening remote so
basically it's reading in the the files
that we just created seeing okay this
Docker file do it did I already created
do have to pull in the base image create
this entire talk file to have it cached
let's figure out all these uh all these
things
so right here you can see okay it's
pulling a couple layers
running uh additional steps for the
layers that you don't have yet
installing everything
exporting to layers make sure it's
cached for the next time
then basically here it's also showing
you okay this is the system that we
currently have
it's not Mac OS but it was a Linux
distribution to kind of show the proof
then actually you can see on the left
hand side
the the repo that we that we created
yeah it's also there it's mounted
and then still running some additional
commands until terminal opens
all right so now in this terminal
maybe print the
the operating system okay we're inside a
Linux machine now
maybe print Java because we wanted to
install Java
okay there's there's Java now
so what I'm trying to do to show to you
now given that maybe you wanted to use a
project with a very specific Java
version
yeah this could be a nice way to to have
it installed for new developers already
it's not like okay go to this website go
to install Java yeah you can uh develop
inside the dev container and have your
entire specification already installed
for you
also
the python first will be specified by
spark it's it's there
all right so
naturally you can also rebuild so yeah
given that you kind of mess up something
corrupt your your environment you can
rebuild the the image get a fresh fresh
environment from start so that might
might help
the Petra for example who messed up her
her virtual environment
right so a lot of stuff was happening in
the images that I was showing where we
were opening the the dev container what
is happening uh else because a lot of
things were actually happening already
for us so actually vs code server is
being installed first on your Dev
container
so what vs code needs is it needs a way
to talk to this container so it will
install actually vs code sort of open up
a port a bridge to have communication
with actually the running container and
your local editor so for that it
installs vs code server and this also
brings us to what is the requirement
like what what does your image need to
support in order to have it usable as a
Dev container this is the most important
requirement like whatever image you
choose
it should be able to run vs code server
and as you may know vs code is
running on a JavaScript engine
vs code server also so your image needs
needs to support node.js for that reason
so a lot of uh images that they support
node so face code will notice okay you
don't have node yet install it install
via to a fees code server open up that
connection so it can talk to your
container
what else right some config is copied
over
your git credentials for example so yeah
you don't have to
reconfigure your username email once
you're actually developing inside this
this container we copy it over just like
SSH known hosts just for convenience
and then also we do a couple file system
mounts for example we just saw that this
container was opening and then at some
point a repo appeared that is actually
because it was opening like a file
system Mount so whatever you edit inside
the container it is actually reflected
on your on your file system it's the
same folder
and also vs code workspace folder so it
gives you kind of some convenience
options so you don't you're not opening
a completely empty Dev environment
all right so given that we just
specified uh our Dev container now we
just have this this Docker file with
this devcontainer.json file we can
basically communicate okay this is all
that's required to set up our
development environment
so now now actually we can also create
like a nice little markdown button
which then takes your like a repo which
is lives on on guitar for example and
then tells vs code to actually clone it
and open it in a Dev container right
away
so you can do this by creating a URL
which is
basically basing of the vs code uh
protocol and then telling it clone in
volume a certain URL
and this is just to show you okay
it it could be a quite nice option to
have like a button in your in your repo
and you click it and it just opens your
your environment right away
right so on the left hand side I just
put
a readme file which uses sort of
conventional install steps okay you have
all the install steps here
and then do all of this to to kind of
get get started in the project
and then on the right hand side
there's the setup with with with the
button
or at least you could say okay this
works with the death container open the
repo you can open up the dev container
so basically you defined all your
installation steps already in your in
your Docker file you have to keep the
docker file up to date when you change
the environment uh teammates can pull it
this is basically like a shorter shorter
version with formalized install
instructions
all right so given that we created this
quite basic Dev container how can we
extend it like our Dev container.json
file still really lightweight so what
what is still missing
uh maybe it's a good safety practice to
install a non-root user
maybe you want to pass in some custom vs
code settings to get the user started a
bit more quickly
um well we're doing uh spark stuff so it
might be nice to access spark UI as well
and then also okay given that we already
yeah dockerized our uh development
environment could we also use it to run
our CI steps like inside this this image
okay let's see let's see how we can can
do these extra steps so starting with
installing a non-root user so for
example just to illustrate that that
indeed also pip is telling you this
um it it's always a good practice if you
have a production image just in the case
uh this this image gets gets hijacked
the hijacker has as little permissions
as as possible so you want to kind of
get the the the user that is basically
running in the in in the in the system
you want to give them as little
permissions as possible so also not to
mess up the the file system it might be
nice uh not to execute everything by on
Route by default
so how do we do this
there's two Linux commands uh relevant
for this a group AD and user ad
basically adds a new user called
non-root in this case
and then this is the important uh part
where we Define inner depth content into
Json file with which username do we want
to log into this container
all right that's very nice when we
started now we were connected as a
non-root instead
all right so let's see then how we can
actually make this user experience a bit
nicer for the for the user not having
them started with zero settings at all
so here you can actually also see a bit
where this open specification comes in
before actually the Assumption was made
that everything was living inside vs
code now they kind of
pulled out
all the the vs code specific stuff and
they made this new key which is called
customizations and then vs code so in
the future hopefully when more editors
join this open specification
it will be customizations and then maybe
also another editor python for example
right so what settings are we giving the
user here we're saying okay install the
python extension for us
um maybe when when you want to do
testing for example with a pie test uh
run it from from this directory uh you
unit tests by test yeah kind of
configuring that giving the user that
already
that is nice let's see how can we access
a spark UI
we're actually
yeah opening up a port which is 4040
giving it a label
uh that's nice now we actually can get
the notification when the sports opens
okay maybe you want to open it which is
spark UI
right so what about CI
then there's two options here either we
pre-built the the image
we uploaded somewhere to some registry
and then we we use that as a an image
for our CI pipeline
or within your CI pipeline you build the
image and then execute commands within
this image
let's go for the first option the second
option is a bit more
complex just to see okay how can we use
CI with our Dev container there's
already a GitHub action for this
I'm kind of speeding up a little a given
amount of time I have left even though
the clock is not giving me feedback
all right so about this uh ci5 line
first we log into maybe registry of your
choice GitHub container registry
then this is using this get the action
that I showed before which is Dev
containers CI
and then just run one simple command in
this by test
so actually we were Opening Our Dev
container just now it opened in vs code
it was nice we have this environment now
running our contains integration is
using the same environment
so if you run Pi test on your on your
local machine
then running your CI it uses the same
environment this is kind of what I
wanted to to stress that that is nice
you you have less chance that that in
your CI oh [ __ ] it works in my CI and
not not here it's the same environment
so it's a bit less likely to go wrong
this is nice it just shows uh like a
GitHub uh action the trace
um where uh in the in the middle it says
build and run depth container task
all right so what is the final
definition
we have this entire Dev container.json
file with some keys build remote user
and the customizations
and then also the port attributes and
forward ports
then next there's the docker file we
install Java a non-root user
and we install the production pip
dependencies in the development
dependencies
so that was great we have these two uh
two definitions basically you get the QR
code in the end so if you want to play
around a bit more with this little
example we built uh feel free to do that
in the end scandi QR code so let's let's
look a bit over the horizon uh now so we
built this this simple Dev container and
kind of explained to you okay what what
may be the the benefits what what what
else is there
so like I said
um that you you can you can mount
directories already mounts One Directory
uh for you but but the pro trip is maybe
you you you work on some Cloud you want
to Mount Your Cloud credential so you
don't have to log in on your local
system and in the dev container twice
there are also Dev container templates
already configured Dev container images
for you which have these known root
users already figured out you can just
get started a bit more quickly maybe
build upon that
and there's also features which is
little Snippets you can you can add for
example you want to use the AWS CLI
Azure CLI this is a kind of like little
snippet you can add to your Dev
container image just convenience
and then maybe most importantly
remote development so there's also been
this trend where you actually connect
also your IDE to not a Docker container
that's running locally but running
remotely
so this is actually exactly what GitHub
code spaces is
and get the code space Also integrates
with the dev container definition so
that is awesome actually on GitHub it
already gives you this this button if
you have Dev container do you want to
open this in a GitHub code space
that is awesome your your users don't
even have to have a an editor installed
just
edit in the browser itself
yeah sure thanks
all right so conclusion Dev containers
allow you to connect your IDE to a
running Docker container
this makes it reproducible and and
getting isolation while still getting a
native experience reproducible means
fast onboarding better alignment with d
members
and a smaller Gap to production
now it's only a feast code but an open
specification is taking shape
so that's it
Dev containers might be able to help
Petra or Eric the old project maintainer
or Johnny Jr
but maybe even you
thank you
thanks a lot for the great book
hi thanks for your talk
um I have one comment and that's the
docker file that you showed doesn't
really ensure that the different
developers will have the same
environment because you always update
your apps index before you install Java
so that's still something that you need
to think about when you set this up
especially if you let developers build
their own image so maybe it's
a suggestion to like prepare an image
and deploy it somewhere that people can
just pull without needing to like do
these installs themselves that's a great
great comment so
yeah indeed I'll uh I'll keep note so
thank you for that
is there any other questions at the
front
so thank you for the talk we're starting
using it uh in my company and the thing
that happened is we had a container it
worked and then sometimes
it break by someone who was not using it
push something update some dependency
now the container is broken do you have
that and is there any way to have that
as part of the CI then it's get a big
meta right how do you test your Dev
container as part of the CI yeah yeah
yeah I I liked how you already answered
the your question uh in the second part
almost
um it indeed it works the best if your
entire team is working on dev container
so indeed you don't have these weird
moments where it breaks uh with the DCI
and indeed this this helps a lot you can
just see whether you broke the dev
container definition if you see how it
feels
so indeed
yeah like I mean if you go to this this
template uh yeah you will see how to how
to run it in NCI as well it works for
GitHub actions and uh Azure Pipelines
I didn't implement this CI action myself
but it's out there
thanks
um yeah thanks I love Dev containers I
think it's a really neat idea
and I would also like to run it remotely
easily what I now do in vs code
is a SSH into a user SSH extension to go
into a remote machine and then I pull my
code there and then I can actually run
the dev container so that's already
quite cool but I would like it even more
if I can do that directly from a local
machine Mount the source code in a
container on kubernetes or a VM or
whatever
and then have an even smoother
experience to develop in a remote
machine and access more compute do you
know if there is a solution around or
being built for for that use case
so you're basically asking okay how can
I get the the
this the same development experience
that I would have like if using it
locally but then with like the power of
using uh VMS for example with SSH
connections all right
yeah okay so uh personally I've also
been kind of fiddling around with this
remote development but then I think
whereas Dev containers this
specification has been kind of uh has
been converging a bit towards one open
specification agnostic of of the editors
I think the remote development stage is
even more like wild
uh so yeah I I I couldn't uh get you
like a solid recommendation on that one
but uh for sure if you find out I have
nice new findings about uh like a proper
workflow with the VMS uh running on a
cloud for example then share with me uh
please so
uh but yeah get get the code spaces is
now very good solution but it's quite
expensive